Speaker 1: So I have new polling from the
Herschel Walker Raphael Warnock race. But
what I want to make sure everybody knows is that
this polling is from before the abortion scandal.
Okay. So it's we don't yet know the effect of
the abortion scandal, but there is some good news
based on new polling. There is a Fox News
poll that now is part of the mix. And I
know people say Fox News, Fox News polling is
actually fine. It's a totally fine pollster
on average. Raphael Warnock is now ahead of
Herschel Walker by 1.3 points. Now, again,
important caveats. All of this polling
is from before the abortion scandal,
and I'm calling it that. I don't believe abortion
is a scandal, but it's the abortion scandal,
meaning Herschel Walker for a year. Campaigning on
abortion is the absolute worst thing in the world,
now credibly accused of having paid for a woman's
abortion after urging her to get that abortion. So
the polling is from before that scandal. We don't
know yet how that scandal will affect the polling.
And number two, this is too tiny a lead to really
bank on, right? So up until a few days ago,
Walker was up by like under one point. Now
Warnock is up by a little over a point. This
is all way too small a lead to assume anything
one way or the other. Everyone must vote. I hope
that you're registered in Georgia, and I hope
that you plan to vote because this is you know,
we talk about what are the most important Senate
races on which this election could could hinge
control of the Senate could hinge Pennsylvania
is at the top of the list, but Georgia is close
as well. FiveThirtyEight has one of these sort
of I don't know what you call it, forecasts,
I think they call it. They're calling the Georgia
Senate election a toss up. But it is swinging
more and more in Warnock's favor. Yesterday they
had it at a 54% chance that Warnock wins. Now,
FiveThirtyEight has it at a 55% chance that
Warnock wins. Now, that's that's basically a coin
flip, right? If you get to flip 100 coins and one
guy wins 55 and the other, you know, it's heads 55
times and tails 45. That's very, very close to
a toss up. And as you can see, there has been a
little bit of a bump recently for Warnock,
but really not much. So we'll see what the
effect of the abortion scandal is. But don't
think for a second that staying home in this
one is a good idea because control of the
Senate could hinge on it. Let's hope that
Warnock grabs a couple of points thanks to
this abortion related Herschel Walker scandal